now there's another you know situation I
was in and the problem is people will
hear parts of the truth but not
understand the whole truth
and not think of things from the 360
point of view and the problem with the
Internet is now it becomes profitable to
expose me and the other problem is
there's I'm gonna do a whole video on
this but these other content creators
are so gung-ho they make money off of
spreading about me so it's like
they'll they'll be partially true right
where the ex-friend comes in and says
well she didn't think like this before
and
partially true right partially like
maybe I didn't I wasn't as loud about my
opinions before because I was playing I
was playing volleyballs working a sales
job what incentive do I have to give my
opinions to a girl I know is kind of
crazy